right now I'm a material science to me
and engineering made everybody also
wanted to do biomedical engineering and
because of Carnegie Mellon's program I
can do both another thing that attracted
me to Carnegie Mellon was how skilled
they also are and teaching the Arts cuz
I love doing choir and music singing all
sorts of things and because of Carnegie
Mellon's diverse programs I'm not I
gotta be able to not only study
engineering but also take choir classes
and immerse myself unlike so many of the
other things they offer it's really
great to see like so many like girls
just like me like getting out wanting
pursuing their dreams and I love how
it's so equal this time and especially
means a lot since engineering is like
typically like not super not that many
women in that field where traditionally
underrepresented so it's really awesome
to be in like my physics and math and
intro classes and like there's so many
girls raising their hands to making up
just like me